مه يوم من الحرب وغزه ضئيله المساحه
والامكانات الكثفه السكان بل التي طالما
وصفت بانها مجرد سجن كبير لا تزال تستعصي
على السقوط امام جحافل الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي سبق له ان هزم جيوش ما كانت توصف
بدول الطوق العربيه مجتمعه واحتل اجزاء
شاسعه من اراضيها في سته
ايام ذاك استثناء فريد ما كان لاحد ان
يتوقع تسجيله في تاريخ الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي قبل ان تبدا تلو ابيب حربها
المدمره بحجه هجوم كتائب القسام الذراع
المسلحه لحركه حماس على المعسكرات
والمستوطنات المحيطه بقطاع غزه يوم السابع
من تشرين اول اكتوبر الماضي الثمن الباهظ
المدفوع فلسطينيا على مذبح الحرب كان وما
زال استثنائيا ايضا
نحو 100 الف ضحيه ما بين شهيد وجريح
ومفقود اي ما معدله الف كل يوم فضلا عن
تشريد مليون و800 الف من بيوتهم وبلداتهم
بعد تسويتها بالارض وهو ما يعني في حساب
الارقام الصماء 18 الف نازح يوميا بينما
منعت عن اهل غزه جميعا امدادات الغذاء
والماء والدواء والكهرباء وال
لم يكن اقل استثنائيه او فراده في ميزات
هذه الحرب كذلك ان يصطفى قاده الغرب خلف
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو متجاهلين الصور
المتدفقه لاشلاء الضحايا الابرياء ولر كام
الاحياء السكنيه ولكل ما اجج الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه في مختلف انحاء العالم الى حد
استثنائي نادر وجد تعبيره في تعالي
الهتافات ضد اسقاط القيم الانسانيه
والحضاريه التي سبق استخدامها حججا للتدخل
في مناطق اخرى من
العالم كانت المقاربه التي روجتها اسرائيل
وتبناها حلفاؤها تقوم على تجاهل سبعه عقود
ونيف من اعمال الغزو والتقتيل والتهجير
التي تعرض له الشعب الفلسطيني قبل السابع
من تشرين اول اكتوبر وقد تمحورت الدعايه
التي رافقت الحرب حول هدف مفاده لي عنق
التاريخ وتصوير الصراع على انه بدا في ذلك
اليوم بهجوم ارهابي فلسطيني ضد سكان
اسرائيليين امنين او حتى ضد ناجين من
المحرقه النازيه وفق روايتهم التي حاولت
ان تحشر في سياق الاحداث عنوه جرائم اباده
ضد اليهود سبقت انشاء اسرائيل على ارض
فلسطين ولم يكن للفلسطينين ين علاقه بها
ارادوا احتكار صفه الضحيه حتى في حقبه
ارتكابهم جرائم ترقى الى مستوى التطهير
العرقي واذ اتسق مع ذلك سيل تصريحات غربيه
ايدت ما سمته حق اسرائيل في الدفاع عن
نفسها فان استثناء اخر جديدا وغير مسبوق
سيقع عشيه اليوم المئه للحرب جلب اسرائيل
لتمثل امام محكمه العدل الدوليه بناء على
دعوه من جنوب افريقيا تتهمها بارتكاب
اباده جماعيه في قطاع غزه على وقع ذلك كله
بدا الجانب الوحيد غير الاستثنائي في
الحرب وتفاعلاتها هو التحرك الدبلوماسي
الامريكي والغربي الذي سعى ابتداء الى فرض
الوصايه على الشعب الفلسطيني وشهد تحت
عنوان البحث في خطط اليوم التالي لانتهاء
القتال طرح سيناريوهات لا يقوم اي منها
على تطبيق قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه او مبدا
حق الشعوب في الحريه وتقرير المصير صحيح
ان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن
اكد اخيرا على ضروره انهاء حرب غزه تمهيدا
لخلق مسار يؤدي الى دوله فلسطينيه ويحقق
الاستقرار المنشود لعزل ايران كما قال غير
انه مازال يرفض وقف اطلاق النار وتلك ليست
احجيه كما قد تبدو للوهله الاولى بقدر
تنطوي على مفهوم للنهايه المشتهاه ينتصر
فيها الاسرائيليون ويستسلم الفلسطينيون
ليعودوا من بعد الى انتظار وعد واشنطن
المتكرر بمنحهم الحق في اقامه دولتهم وهو
وعد سمعوه واختباره على مدى عقود سلفت فلم
يحصدوا غير الخيبه الممهور دوما باستمرار
استباحه دمهم واعتقال ابنائهم وهدم بيوتهم
واستيطان ارضهم وتهويد مق
هذه بضاعه امريكيه قديمه في غلاف جديد قال
فلسطينيون كثر محذرين من شرائها بينما
واصلت غزه الجريحه تقديم الدليل تلو
الدليل على ان الاستسلام المرتجى
اسرائيليا وامريكي ليس واردا في حساباتها
وان النهايه الوحيده التي يقبلها الشعب
الفلسطيني لكفاح التاريخي هي الحريه الان
او غدا او بعد دهر ah